I am surprised to Victoria we have our
own private chase rice concert the past
is about to come back to haunt Victoria
F on The Bachelor I feel so bad the
Virginia Beach native has pretty much
flown under the radar on Peter Webber
season flown Pete the pilot pun intended
anyway all that's about to change
next week the promo at the end of
Monday's episode shows Victoria getting
a one-on-one date with Peter where her
ex-boyfriend chase rice was the musical
guest Jason I did awkward
so was it a genius move by producers or
any total coincidence I guess we'll find
out next week but for now here's
everything you might want to know about
Chase and his past romance with Victoria
starting with this he's actually been on
reality TV - well he may be a country
singer now his resume is super all over
the place he was a college football
linebacker a former NASCAR pit crew
member and a former contestant on
Survivor put my neck on the line early
on planning on doing that
yep the 34 year old competed on Survivor
Nicaragua in 2010 and he came in second
next up his musical career is on fire
his first studio album Friday nights and
Sunday mornings was released in 2010 and
he scored his first number-one single on
country radio last year with his 2017
track eyes on you number two on our list
he dated Victoria before the bachelor so
we don't know a whole lot about their
love but we do know that they dated
before she went on the show and they
were serious enough or recent enough for
her to be embarrassed by him it's
showing up on her date with Peter Jason
ID and last but not least he actually
joked et about dating Hannah brown yeah
like former bachelorettes beauty queen
Alabama Hannah windmill smooching with
Peter Hannah brown hey I need to go meet
her you're the second person to bring
her up let's do it
honestly this season of The Bachelor has
not let us down
I mean last week we had the scandal of
all scandals champagne gate
what's that I heard a pop I don't did
don't you're looking puppet and last
night was all about Alea the whole
champagne thing was just bound to
explode who was sent home after a lot of
girls told Peter she was fake AF I could
tell something's off about that girl
you're a bit you're fake okay
she is just all fake she puts on the
pretty little princess facade maybe oh
yeah like maybe you put on a little bit
for the just for the imagery of things
and also after a lot of back and forth
with Peter about it I don't even know
what the hell just happened and I guess
I would love to get your your ID at
which I am very confused I mean I'm
pretty confused too but all that went
down after Demi be from Colton season
slash bachelor in paradise returned to
coordinate one epic pillow fight group
date situation alright so I know that
there's a lot of tension in the mansion
I've been in the middle of it before so
I get it so I wanted to give you ladies
the opportunity to let out that
aggression and the best way I know how
and IMI's extreme pillow fight club I
feel right at home being back here you
know I love helping out the bachelor
franchise ET was on the set when it all
went down and got the inside scoop from
Demi herself I'm gonna keep my eyes
peeled on all of these ladies I can't
have anybody messing with my boy Peter I
know that there's some girls who I think
have really fun energy and I would like
to see him with but I'll just have to
see that's his decision to make
well I'm officially on board Pete season
but a bunch of course you can count on
et to keep you up to date on all things
pilot Pete and this season of The
Bachelor so make sure to keep it locked
or right here until next time I'm Hallie
Stevens bye for now
[Music]